santes sickology rossa et des femmes qui
sont gros seins jusqu'à dimanche qu'à
terme elle dit non non je ne suis pas
enceinte et je pense que le monde
occidental un déni de la guerre parce
qu'on dit par exemple c'est la première
fois qu'à la guerre sur le continent
européen depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale c'est faux c'est faux la guerre
en yougoslavie
c'était beaucoup plus proche sûr que
l'ukraine et veinules km2 - il ya eu 140
mille morts
deuxième chose dit mais écoutez on
s'attendait pas à la guerre dans cette
région du monde depuis 2014 il y avait
eu quatorze mille morts dans le conflit
entre la russie les soi disant petits
hommes verts qui n'ont rien à voir mais
russe en réalité l'armée russe
évidemment on a bien compris et les
troupes ukrainienne 14000 barre donc
c'est la poursuite de cette guerre par
d'autres moyens à une autre échelle une
certaine façon la russie n'a fait
qu'officialiser son intervention
militaire au donbass et généralisé
ailleurs condom bas cette intervention
c'est le premier point je pense qu'on a
un déni de la guerre pourquoi on a ce
délit de la guerre parce que quand vous
êtes puissant quand vous vivez dans un
monde qui vous ressemblent quand vous
avez netflix quand viennent les
supermarchés plein quand vous êtes les
rois du monde vous pensez que vos
valeurs sont dominantes dans le monde
vous ne voulez pas la guerre vous voulez
la paix et c'est une histoire éternelle
de l'humanité ceux qui veulent la guerre
sont ceux qui veulent renverser l'ordre
ou ceux qui en effet sont humiliés par
l'ordre établi premier point deuxième
point coûté la première guerre mondiale
avant la première guerre mondiale on a
dit c'est impossible qu'il y ait une
guerre tant les économies de la grande
bretagne l'allemagne sont intriqués
c'est un livre très célèbre norman un
goal 1911 fera jamais de guerre entre la
grande bretagne et l'allemagne les
millions de morts plus tard on aurait pu
s'attendre à ce que l'humanité se disent
bombe à cette fois ci on va sortir de ce
rêve les pacifistes sont des gens
extrêmement dangereux
bernadeaux sadi les optimistes ont pas
pitié des hommes il faut bien établir la
différence entre pacifique et passifs
historienne est impossible aujourd'hui
moi je suis pas du tout bien sûr moi je
suis pas du tout pacifiste je pense qu'à
des choses qui sont pire que la mort la
soumission est pire que la mort perdre
dans sa dignité vivre comme un esclave
c'est pire que la mort il faut être prêt
à faire la guerre mais évidemment il
faut considérer se rappeler que la
guerre c'est ce qui est pire donc il
faut tout donc s1 c'est être pacifique
ces broutilles mais c'était
incontrôlable pour google ou pas c'est
une autre question mais justement je
voulais dire seconde guerre mondiale et
voyez c'est je voudrais pas qu'on ait
soit obligé de rejouer est temps de
remettre un jeton pour vérifier une
troisième fois que l'humanité ne sortira
pas de son état naturel c'est-à-dire
belliqueux on ne supprimera pas la
guerre personne alors il ya la question
de l'armé nucléaire qui est liée à la
psychologie de possibles moi je suis pas
psychologue j'ai pas d'informations sur
poutine je vois les informations je vois
que ce type n'a plus le même visage
qu'il ya ne serait-ce qu un an ça laisse
à penser qu'il a des traitements
probablement des traitement à la
cortisone
ça fait des années qu'on fantasme sur la
maladie de puccini mais il a changé
physiquement le président de la
république l'a dit il a constaté
lui-même on le voyant des visuels
puisque les images mais il ya quand on
voit les gens c'est différent deuxième
chose il ya ces protocoles dont on a
entendu parler c'est à dire que même
dans son entourage il n'y a pour lui une
paranoïa ou co-leader pourquoi une
paranoïa aucun vide parce que
vraisemblablement son système
immunitaire n'est pas le mien est le
vôtre c'est à dire que les effets du
vaccin ou les effets du co vite sur
quelqu'un qui a dit qu'à une immunité
très très faible probablement c'est un
péril de mort
donc si cette hypothèse est vrai ça veut
dire qu'il est probablement physiquement
très affaibli ensuite c'est ce qui a été
dit par le général desportes est très
vrai il ne vit pas dans notre monde il
n'a pas le même rapport à la guerre à la
paix il a pas le même rapport à l'ordre
qu'il considère lui comme humiliant pour
la russie est dangereux pour la russie
et ainsi de suite mais il se peut
également qu'ils aient perdu un peu le
contact avec la réalité s'est rapidement
22 monde nous avons une part de
responsabilité nous européens et aussi
les américaines ce qui se passe ou pas
du tout rapidement bien sûr la
culpabilité c'est poutine à 100% il a
commis une erreur d'appréciation massive
manifeste et il a fait quelque chose de
criminel eu égard au droit international
il est indéfendable
mais la responsabilité bien sûr la
responsabilité les partager et
d'ailleurs il faut arrêter de tomber
dans ce manichéisme ce n'est pas les
gentils ukrainiens face aux méchants
russes la méchante autant face à la
gentille et russie ce sont deux
puissances qui se regardent en chiens de
faïence et si on comprend que les
polonais sont très inquiets par la
perspective d'être envahi par les russes
parce que c'est l'histoire qui veut ça
on peut tout à fait comprendre que les
russes soient très inquiets par la
perspective d'être attaqué par l'ouest
parce qu'ils ont été plus c'est ça qui
est intéressant millions de morts